yes oh we're on everybody this is date
fails I'm Kate Quigley uh yeah this is
like a special episode of date fails
today I'm calling it the wild now
episode by the way I have MTV people on
the show and I'm like I'm 57 years old
but you guys are both on this season of
wild or now on MTV that's so dope how
excited are you
you guys sound thrilled that was like
January February is weird thing about
show business isn't it that you tape
[ __ ] and forget about it and then it
airs and then everybody's like people
come up to me and they're like are you
excited to host the AV I know what like
it's still happening I'm like that was
seven eight months ago yeah that's been
but what was it like
tell me about taping it um typing it was
fine so fun it was a lot of energy a lot
of good chemistry a lot of just you know
everybody there is funny most 90% of the
people there were funny yeah about a
cricket song really need that really
funny yeah where did you guys shoot it
CBS a lot by the Grove also here in LA
so they were like we were I think on the
first day where we got removed when we
went to shoot and they had built the
stage they were like you know we got
James Corden right here and they don't
want a lot of pot smoke floating around
a lot are you serious
well I got Becky Rob and said Becky I
feel like you're blowing up I feel like
you always
yeah like when I met Becky the first
time I saw you I was like that girl's
gonna be this big star and then now it's
just like I see you everywhere you're
everywhere no you know you have like all
the hair I'm faking it with a lot of
curls lungs and bronzer until people are
like
you could maybe be on TV stop thank you
you're killing it you're so funny I you
guys have to follow her on instagram
because what I love about you is all the
characters you do oh yeah you know yeah
I like that I feel like you're gonna end
up on SNL or something better or
something better man that's what I was
saying I was really it's beneath us and
now at this point like she should just
do movies we're doing workshop I was
like this is I hate to compare people
but if I had to compare it I would
compare it to like a Jim Carrey I was
just like she she's not afraid she's not
a you know she's not scared
I felt like when we when we started
workshopping like every kind of had to
like be in a lane and I was like that
this is all I can do so I guess I'm just
gonna try to do it tenfold and you know
and yeah but it is like such an
endearing quality because you are a
beautiful woman and when you're a
beautiful girl a lot of people are
afraid to look stupid
or look ugly or look shitty and you will
post a video where you're like purposely
trying to look like fattest fog or super
butch or just I mean and and it's like
that makes you so attractive I think
it's so hot we'll get to that and then I
got Teddy Rea Teddy how did we meet we
do a stand-up actually you know how here
any stand up straight yeah yeah for sure
and then we made out we made out on
video
they never aired it we did white people
kissing black people for the first time
however the title was we did that video
and they went pretty it went pretty big
that video got so many it's up tons of
heads like 4 million I think on Facebook
I mean on YouTube and then something
like that I think yeah got in a million
so it's amazing
we're like it was it is weird the stuff
that goes viral I think it's never what
you think will go viral you've had viral
stuff what did your mcdonald's proposal
video when went viral what was
I didn't think that was gonna go well
you know it's like I was like this we
almost didn't post it we're like this
isn't good at all so awkward that people
it yes yeah for sure like the video that
I shot with Waka Flocka so I had this
video well cuz word of mouth started
travelling about people like Dec Kate
I'm walking like I know it was so
embarrassing because we staged that
whole video the whole thing was set up
like I was like well I'm gonna torque on
you like bad white girl dancing and then
you just look at me like I'm [ __ ]
and just walk off but we didn't tell
anyone else in that hallway that we were
gonna do it and so what we did it
everyone thought it was real yeah and I
have never in my life got so much hate I
got so many hate messages for you cuz
he's married and people like you who are
trying to homewrecker trying to wreck a
marriage and I was like oh my like I was
just trying to be stupid like I just
thought it was funny
they don't understand that this is all
fun and games for what the weaves Monken
challenged me and oh boy do we got a
show Teddy Roberto boy and what was a
challenge just to smoke the Mo's we can
smoke the most we whoever taps how far
is whoever's like oh I can do this no
more you know losing how much weed did
you smoke like how is it measured I
think you can tell I don't smoke
available that day I think we had damn
near like a half an ounce we didn't
smoke all of it but we got close well
what was your device we just like papers
bongs everything everything where did
you shoot this yeah with our death in
Long Beach and wanted the producers
house there was the rest of your day
like
don't understand we don't understand
that the rest of your day is lovely yes
okay nobody piss you off okay nobody
really irritates you yeah you do I don't
I I don't take and eat animals a lot
because I yeah
but I I smoke a good amount here in
there yeah really yeah I should more
dudes always try to get you to smoke in
jail because I feel like that's my game
right now so much and then I don't stand
up like a lot of our stuff that we do
without so when I yeah I don't want to
say I don't want to take a girl out but
I've seen all that yeah you know it'd be
hard for me to act excited around
something yeah no I I don't do that I'll
just like if I smoke I like do it when
I'm like home and I'm like I need unwind
I'll just like smoke my back deck alone
and like listen to music and I eat a
gang of food Oh like I don't I don't
really want guys to take me on date
dates like I know what you mean like I'd
rather just chill coming out all the
time so I'm your one night off I kind of
want to do nothing but you know the
problem with that is all my girlfriend's
like you gotta make them take you out
because if you start out just chilling
once the duel starts being active you'll
start a knack you know he'll take you to
where those guys is no it's taken me
working on my life in these streets
walking past where they sitting in the
bushes they might that do you love your
life slash future millionaire season at
the bus stop right now the bus stop
think millionaires future millionaires
are riding a lot of buses do you think
the hardest yeah cuz it's a different
way man it's like of course you got the
millionaire's already the board right of
course they know but then they
[ __ ] they hello where they are they
like they booty played with sometimes
nothing wrong no things though that you
you got to do what they want alright now
we're in the pants cuz they got the
dough
have you dated a millionaire Teddy I
don't care what she did she shower you
with gifts did you like that you like
having a girl that makes like a lot of
money she's making more than you yeah I
don't mind it but this is I'm gonna I'm
a very Viper person like it don't really
matter how much money you will make
yeah if our vibe is off I can't I can't
yeah the money helps I see why girls
mess with foods with money because I was
definitely like I was you know lost in
the sauce you don't want to look back if
you dated millionaires if you did it
really wealthy not I don't think a
millionaire but yet the six-figure zone
for sure but it was just it was too much
too fast and I didn't like that I was
also fresh out of a thing but like I
would come home and there would just be
like flowers like and I'm not that maybe
I could like grow to be that type of
girl but I'm like I'm getting these
flowers with this like little teddy bear
and I'm like the teddy bear was small
here you go pups like when guys do that
it kind of freaks me out
yeah cuz I'm just like what do you think
what do you need what are you trying to
get out of this like I don't need the
gifts I already like you just a little
too much too soon but also they're
giving you flowers and a teddy bear that
says to me like that they don't know you
that well to know that you're not like a
right turn out they're tight yeah yeah
it's like you maybe you just don't get
me that's really weird I'm a box full of
different color do rags
I know this is from the bottom of my
heart Becky I got the two-tone colors
pink
I got the whole Hogan version the box of
a sort of do's I would drop trou
immediately that's what's on Becky's
Amazon wishlist is just do-rags
I don't know do you have an Amazon
wishlist by the way now no but I have a
fun baby thinking about it do you know
what I don't you know why I I know no
you should like all my friends are like
you should cuz of course I have a lot of
friends that have them but there's
something that makes me just feel weird
about like assuming people would want to
send me gifts like I just feel and I
also feel guilty too like we don't make
a lot of money people think if you work
in entertainment like yeah I have a TV
show I live in a [ __ ] I have a guy
living in my kitchen I mean like paying
half my rent like but I still feel weird
to have a TV show and then be like send
me things instead like I think I feel
like people should just give their money
to like beautiful I remember somebody
saying once it did you do a live stream
once and you were on third people
sometimes that send you money online
like they paid you and I have been on
periscope before and people will be like
so I will do that like I'll be at Target
and then I'll be periscoping and then
someone will be like you need that cape
and I'll be like cool get me the Cape so
I've had people buy [ __ ] from me on
periscope before yes
does this something neat about that yeah
but I never asked for it it's just more
like if someone offers then in the
moment yeah yeah sure yeah I could take
it yeah but then in that sense I don't
feel guilty because I kind of feel like
they're paying for the entertainment of
the whatever dumb [ __ ] I'm doing on
periscope you know what I mean yeah that
shouldn't you give up that time for like
you're you keep it up for free whatever
you're doing right yeah
that's basically like prop money petty
yeah it's a company card okay with that
or if people want to send me like
bikinis like it's something I'm using
for oh that's different you know do you
that's nice I love ya like no guy is
turning that like Sam tripolis like are
you kidding me I'd have a [ __ ] he's
like I'd have everything on Amazon and
have people buying my whole paying my
bills out like doing it all yeah I don't
know maybe we should maybe she'll think
about I'm gonna think about this yeah
cases of coconut water you know I think
so yeah dude what if you what if you had
somebody paying for your boxes of toilet
paper that would be dope that's a good
idea
I'm gonna I'm gonna put up all very
essentials yeah like the the calming
pouch calming powder that I snore since
I quit cooking like melatonin no dude
this is real there's I have anxiety
probably you actually snore that trying
to get off drugs so what I buy is this
stuff it's called calming powder and
it's like this magnesium powder and
you're supposed to drink it and it's
supposed to make you calm but I snort it
instead Wow
because I think it'll make me calm
faster so when I'm thinking now I pour a
little out and I cut lines of it and i
snort and it's actually a citrus
flavored so bursting learned your nose a
little bit but you kind of feel a little
high for a second you know and also it
makes you [ __ ] even if you snort it and
I'm only saying that because you know if
you have a problem keeping regular go on
Amazon look for the calming powder it
flattens your I think you should do a
commercial
they're gonna stop selling their stop
sending it Kate can't have that anymore
Becky you you're single now no in the
market yeah is that right yeah what's up
with that where you mean were you
getting some digger
what's your life right side up in the
deals I know and I was just when I just
went home to Oregon and I was like in
people my friends are my eyes go they
were like it's like you made it dude
like you made it and I was trying to
figure out how to explain in some way
and this is the only way I can explain
it it's like if making it at this point
means that I have more random dick pics
and my DMS and dollar bills and my bank
accounts then yes I made it yeah but
like that's that's all I got
I'm so single man I just all I have are
like strangers sending me videos of them
jerking off and it's enough right now
how many of those do you average now
like a couple of day isn't that crazy
yeah but every now and then somebody
will take it too far and be like yeah
you like that [ __ ] and I'll block them
because I'm like don't you don't you
talk to me like I don't do you like
talking [ __ ] to me like I hate getting
those surprised ticks in my DMS I hate
it eyes you have tits excited to I don't
know why likes I'd rather get tits to be
honest would you rather get the tits and
dicks I kind of like it all if it's like
if it's okay look it's like looking at
porn you know sometimes you go across
the thumbnail you're like nope I don't
like that but if it's a good one you're
like okay I will tune into this really
and I get excited yeah I need more than
dick I need like body yeah if it's just
a dick with no well you can see a little
bit of the a band that there's that I
like by Adam okay with yeah but but
don't send me that San Jose you guys are
setting me dicks start sending them to
at Becky our Rob
and snap it's just becky Rob it's just
Becky Rob on snap or that dick how many
naked photos are you getting in your
diems oh not three a day maybe like
three a week maybe wow it's so
interesting to me social mean yeah yeah
yeah the story is crazy cuz you you're
like you're you start rooting for them
you're like come on finish yeah dude I
never I guess I'm just not I get tons
but I don't like no I know I have gotten
so many offers to do porn since the AVN
Awards like if I wanted to have a very
successful career you could do it today
I'd be doing porn
I'd be so rich if I had take it
everything but I just I couldn't do it I
can't do it you know that yeah do you
think a little porn adjacent corner
Jason oh nothing it's not even nudes of
me really nowhere
I can't find one um thank God you can't
I know everybody who has them and I have
to have my lawyers and letters to uh
like when I get drunk and I send out
news of my face and I have my lawyer
follow up with the letter like if you
ever post that we will sue you yeah damn
some nudes I've never sent a nude to
anyone nope I've masturbated on FaceTime
sure yeah the guy do you worry that
he'll record that I don't know how he
would what like I use his phone yeah I
just never have like I take a lot of
pictures I've just recently started like
taking even pictures like in my
underwear like I'm very I don't know why
I just didn't like it's never something
that I've thought of doing yeah I sent
him as an apology nudes yeah when I [ __ ]
up real bad or when I go I actually been
doing a bit about it on stage now
because I I'm a really bad texture I
over text what is that do you guys hear
that yeah sounds like there's a car I
don't know what's going on this is just
drama I do like if I send a guy like a
bunch of crazy text messages and then I
realized that I've been crazy then I'll
just send a naked photo don't be like
can we just start over huh and I hope
that fixes that works yeah you did
surprising it does quite a bit of damage
control the nudes it really does no
naked bodies do any type of damage
control even yeah in person picture show
up at his house butt naked he don't
forget whatever it is true like you
could be in the middle of a fight and
then if you just start hooking up and
yeah that naked it seems to solve things
yeah yeah and I like that sex the best
when they're mad at me right you know
cuz it's a little bit of aggression
taken out on your lady parts
mhm stronger pulse
baby stronger to be standing up longer
how do you meet girls could you be more
specific
that's the kind of boot when I met in
the tomb
I talk to girls I show sometimes you
know like audience grows but I try to
like this weird girls who are fans I try
to kind of limit that I'm wondering like
a real often I want to grow who cares
nothing about what I did so it's kind of
you be trying to talk to me like yeah
you don't want to bring up what you're
doing I want to go ahead and she don't
carry that [ __ ] but at some point she
got it yeah
but to poor girls
because for us it's easy if there's a
guy in the audience and you wanted to go
out with him but you're a girl it could
be a guy anywhere if you want to go out
with them right you just go up to it
like you must pick up tons of dudes I
know I don't know guy don't I don't
think not for me you don't want to back
you know maybe deep down I don't want to
but also I'm just too weird I think like
process cuz like I'll get ready and then
I go out with like sometimes even when I
go out like after I have makeup on or
like even when we were gonna show
sometimes and I would like go through
hair and makeup I'd be like [ __ ] like I
don't feel like myself almost yes like
deep down like I was and I think it has
a lot to do with the fact that I was a
really ugly ass kid growing up and so I
like learn that like if I wanted to
attract a guy was gonna have to be
through some type of performance piece
yes yeah and I've always tried to like
hang out with people who are
better-looking than me so I've always
been used to like people coming up and
being like introduce me to your friend
you know and like yeah I don't know so
when I meet guys they like you know look
however I look and then I start talking
they're like she's [ __ ] weird yeah
but guys like must love that I feel like
guys look I think you just got on the
right guy before him about a lot of guys
in LA though don't I don't think like
goofy girls are there at least the ones
I've met I don't know you're sexy thank
you but I don't
but like you are first of all you've got
in like six shape in last year like I
don't know what you're doing what do you
do it you're dancing and the equinox
membership for about a couple months did
some best buds classes
and I just dance yeah dancing I run a
lot oh you run yeah idea yeah because I
mean you look your Instagram now I
noticed like you post sexy photos they
try you get in you get sexy so I feel
like if you just she's direct dude to
your Instagram because guys are visual
let's see those photos and then they'll
see like you're goofy but then you got
this like sexy but for a guy is like so
easy to just pluck girls out of the
audience right it's not easy
here's here's the comedy game you wait
for that lay out for her to come away
let out the show let out everybody's
whatever who trying who wants a big yeah
so do you find it there's somebody who
will like do a little bit more go little
fight like are you so funny and then
like wants to hang around for a little
extra conversation yeah you know that's
why I wasted time knock it away I spent
10 minutes with you I could have been
chopping down another tree yeah yeah you
live in Pomona
sometimes comedy you go home at night by
yourself
I know but like how often let's say you
get offstage and you're trying to get
some how often do you score like one out
of how many times that you try you'll
actually get somebody to come home with
you I'm always just curious how it is
for the guy I said okay okay
again I don't shoot my shot as often as
most comics some comics they hound every
[ __ ] after the show I try to pick one
hang on
right I pick one hang on maybe get her
contact Kiki Witter I'm not really a
first night kind of guy and
yeah I like that you know I like so like
hang with her first before anything at
all yeah usually that's all I can say is
that I'm looking for you but this brings
me to my next question of the day which
is I need personal advice on so this is
good here we go okay so I've been seeing
a guy that I like I really do I like him
he's cool as [ __ ] and he's actually nice
and he actually treats me well and
normally I'm not into that but I'm
trying really hard to turn over a new
leaf
and date a nice person right but I don't
want to [ __ ] him yet I'm not saying I
don't ever want to [ __ ] we've been out
on four dates okay no [ __ ] anything at
all just make out that's it that's it he
doesn't even push to get it past know
which actually makes me kind of
concerned a little so that's my question
is one at what point do I decide that
he's gay if he doesn't make a move
further cuz I'm never like the first one
to like I need the guy to be the
aggressor and to how many dates would
you go on before you you give up on a
girl like how long would you wait that's
what I want to know I mean you don't
really think he's gay
I don't think he's Gabe no I don't well
I don't think he's Gabe I've never I'm
just so used to guys trying to [ __ ] I
know I know I know that I it's no use do
you want are you like eager to [ __ ] him
no okay yeah dude dude he's a real dude
he could probably pick up on that like
she's she's not even concerned with my
dick right now yeah she's not showing my
that's really the fire y-you know I
haven't been like sexual with that's how
I can tell though that he's like a nice
guy yeah I don't want to [ __ ] it up
because I haven't been with him how I
usually I'm
drunk and some like hot phone I'm not
doing that [ __ ] cuz he's actually like
got potential I feel like this could be
one of those is the guys that I've dated
that I've been like they're too nice
we've been like friends for a little
while and I'm not eager to just like
jump their bones those are sometimes the
best relationships but you're like
you're more friendly with them and not
so much like romantic I want to [ __ ] you
all the time yeah but it's like it's
almost best you gotta figure out like
what kind of relationship you really
like because I always fight more with
the really romantic type of relationship
dude but the nice guy you're like you're
too nice you gay like that right I think
I'm not almost too nice I'm not gonna
wait all four times making out yeah we
here's the thing we haven't been in a
place for him to whip it out no we're
like we've gone so we're going at it for
the first three to be honest like I'm
really careful about like letting guys
pick me up until I kind of know them cuz
I've had a couple like stalker sketch
things so I meet I met up with him the
first three times I met him out the
first three nights and you never went
back to one of the others house you
haven't done that you know now date the
last time I met him at his place and
then he drove so I was in his place but
he had like a maintenance guy and
they're doing some work and it was the
beginning of the date then yeah
afterwards I didn't go back in I love
well to be fair to him I had a show so I
had to go so like we went and got food
and I had to leave purposely I purposely
been scheduling the dates so that I
can't stay over come in so cuz part of
me is like I think he was afraid that I
don't know
I'm afraid to hook up with them that I'm
gonna [ __ ] it up
you're not going to I don't know you got
to do is throw it back in a cycle yeah I
mean and what if then I'm also like a
bit of what if the sex is not good I
like him then it's done that's why you
yeah you gotta see that and you just see
him with no shirt I haven't even seen
him with no shirt touched his body a
little okay yeah good I mean we've just
made out a little like end of date make
out like that's it he also hasn't like I
need a guy okay like when you're on a
date with a guy I need the guy I fall
for guys that are like a PDA ish hmm
when we're out like guys that like will
kiss me in public come up behind me and
put their arms around me when I'm
ordering whatever like when guys are
affectionate with me in that way then
everything moves faster this guy's a
little more I can tell he's a little
more distant yeah and I'm not the gonna
ever be the girl to like these overly
affectionate was somebody desires if I
like attack you if like that means we
have no future because I only get super
aggressive with guys that are hyper
toxic Wow and I know that I'm like
really attracted to toxic so if I'm like
I'm just gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] out of this one
and I just go for it in my head
somewhere I know he's not a real thing
this is funny because my roommates doing
the exact same thing right now with a
dude and uh and I've been like trying to
wrap my head around what it is with her
but it's like I think it's something
that kind of has to do a little bit with
like the nature of the dates you're
going on like you've only been that like
what dinner drinks with a dinner dinner
lunch yeah you should do something out
of the box yeah and then see you know do
something like different I think so yeah
get in the water so
I don't know beach beach yeah go for a
little paddleboard people don't like to
go outside no more
does he like yes yes yeah he's into that
[ __ ] okay yeah he's like that he's
outdoors that's the thing is like he's
not a comic he's a business guy okay
actually have so much in common and and
he's cute he's a little short I think
that's why I haven't tried to fog you
know he's like just a couple inches
taller than me but I'm not used to that
I go for like I mean I dated one guy who
was really sure and we did have really
great chemistry but other than that I've
always gone for like tall guys but your
bodies will match up well in bed you
know so that's nice yeah that's true
that's good do something active with him
and then see if you want to [ __ ] him and
then do it if you want to and don't rock
climbing yeah let him see that ass when
you belay down spread the legs with this
workout would you spin around in the
sheets that really sexy thing yes yeah
hot yeah he's athletic I mean he's he's
he's good all right I'm gonna do that
then you can make like a lot of sexual
it's a good catch cuz I'm not even being
mice like I'm being myself but I'm being
like the best version like to take home
to mom version of myself I'm not being
like the usual version like I I mean
like if he saw my Twitter by the way the
best part is my friend my friend Jax and
I'm like do you think this guy's gonna
quit see Meeks I haven't [ __ ] him and
my friend Jackson it's like well if he
looks at your Twitter and he sees how
much you talk about [ __ ] people
but I gonna stop hanging out with you
soon because I do post that but I'm like
keeping all that I'm being like being
like the Ohio Kate with him try to hide
and be somebody else I think I can I
just asked him not to look at my social
media there you go yeah it's fine thank
you thank you Jesus no stay away yeah
you know is he on social media Twitter
and the a but he doesn't really use it
or like I yes that's alright and on
Instagram you're fine yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think I think you guys are
right alright this was this is a good
talk I hope this helped actually I do
yeah I did I'm gonna take him on a
sporting event I don't know it's weird
cuz it's like if you're not really eager
to like dice I know anything even there
and it's like is he too nice I don't
know I know that's the problem though is
for me I've never had and in between
it's either the [ __ ] is and the guy
Sox or the guys really really nice but
he's a little he's sending me teddy
bears and [ __ ] I've never had it in the
middle have you guys had it in the
middle but you also like trying to like
choke her out and bad and stuff and
you're like that
got a slight choke like you know I'm
from behind what about you have you ever
had a guy that was like the perfect
blend of both not yet no it's either
been too nice at the point where I'm
like this I can't you're too nice or
just too mean to the point where I'm
like you're killing me
I'm telling you that's the problem yeah
I think at some point you have to choose
whether you want the hot hot passion and
or you want to be treated well I hate to
say it I think we all eventually in the
end want to be treated well yeah like 10
years we don't mind being treated like
yeah baby you'll be your life somebody
dog you out for a solid ten years you
know what I want I want I want a convict
who was reformed in jail and becomes
like some kind of like you know really
maybe not like a born-again Christian
but just like a really good quality like
person who like sees the light and he
comes out so he knows he's had like that
like I killed people yeah yeah yeah but
now he's like real sweet so he can do
both you need an ex bad boy where do you
find that that's call me if you've been
to jail and you're fixed a lot of those
do is work at FedEx right back to those
bus stop dudes man I think that's I
remember when I had you on date fails
before when it was over at uh
Lovitz Club yeah Williams did you tell
me that used to pick up guys off uber is
that you yeah I would like every now and
then if I was going out like I would
sometimes cancel and be like let's see
if we can get someone hotter I thought
that was so I thought of you forever she
said she would like try to find a hot
uber drivers and then that's how she
would meet Matt just like wherever cuz
everybody there's so even like you guys
ever post mates [ __ ] yeah I haven't
tried post mates oh my god I need to get
on it I was I was one of the first
people yeah order so if in case you
don't have post mates where you live
it's basically like you can order
anything and someone delivers it so you
could be like I would like an apple from
the grocery store right now and that's
how some post mates person show up with
that it's gonna cost $9 yeah yeah yeah
if you [ __ ] up or something and you
want an apple well I don't know why I
chose app you can tell I'm like such a
like health nerdy desert like I can
bring you anything and you brought up
apple can you or delete on post mates I
think that's one of the few things you
can't get out yeah you know TV yeah my
homie ordered two s boxes right this was
back when we were doing any legal tanks
what yeah yeah yeah with Xboxes well
don't Xbox is okay one stolen house
might pay for it we just never paid post
mates oh [ __ ] oh now we're giving like
illegal advice on here Oh your card like
you didn't go through and you it is
never you know make new accounts right
yeah oh my god that's insane
I am I too stupid to you think it's just
a thing I think was living in like an LA
or New York type of city is that like
dude some of these guys dropping off
your McDonald's you're just like I will
bring you inside right now man actors
you know that like maybe they're out of
work for a little while yeah I'm like
some kind of linger in the doorway a
little bit like trying to see a song at
the time you know you're answering it's
like 3:00 a.m. you done with shows for
that you answered a little drunk no I
haven't either but I'll tell you
something barest by all the food that
he's dropping off that's like you know
I'm just like sorry you here by yourself
oh dude no I go to Ralph's there's a
Ralph's by my house okay I go there all
the time at like 2:00 2:30 in the
morning when like The Improv coach yeah
over the [ __ ] I go there and buy ice
cream and popcorn yeah and the checkout
guy one night he actually said to me he
was like wow out of ice cream again
already
so it's hella embarrassing my favorite
thing there - this is actually really
cute it's like the the checkout guy he
knows I do stand-up I don't know how
I've never told him but I apparently he
doesn't know that I actually like work
or have a career yeah because every time
I come in he'll go
so how standup going and I'll be like
it's going great and he'll go keep
plugging away someday you might get you
know a gig
thank you yeah ice cream in the morning
do you ever go in there and like buy
champagne or anything like champagne
I'll get stuff to go with it because I
don't want to look like a weirdo for
just picking a bra and something else it
was just a bad combination sitting on
the no I don't I don't even try to make
myself look cool I also buy dumb [ __ ]
like do you ever just go to the dollar
store yeah yeah I feel like I could see
you doing that like guys think they have
to try so hard to impress us with like
fancy dates I would die for a dude to
take me the dollar store and have me 20
bucks and be like getting whatever you
want people sent me questions to ask so
let's answer some of these these fan
questions these are good questions
here's a great one at what age do you
think it's weird or you would not go out
with someone if they told you they were
still a virgin
what was it like if someone told you
they were still a virgin is there a
certain age where you'd be like I can't
date you or would you still go out with
them or how do you feel about dating a
virgin
anything over 26 you need to grow to
[ __ ] up and get you some [ __ ] in your
life yeah I think 26 you know it's like
a lot of good girls still out there you
know I ate it I waited it out like 25 24
or something they weren't in high school
getting it in yeah I was but it's not at
some point myth even you gay or you
unless you're like super religious and
you're waiting for marriage or that
that's the only people I can think of
that like you never meet someone who's a
virgin by accident my other roommates a
virgin yeah who might the day the exam
really the other ones yeah 25 it's a
girl Wow
what's she waiting hot very hot great
dates and stuff but like just never
never did has she done not a lot not a
lot of I think a lot of like sex stuff
Wow that I know I mean that yeah but uh
yeah like went to you know went to some
went to like a university like where you
know you [ __ ] I'm like I'm wondering
yeah that's it's so great she's got to
be like yeah well it's got yeah that's
why I don't know if I were to meet a guy
like that I'd be like damn what happened
like I would want to know what happened
and then if it's like if it's a
religious yeah no I don't know that
would be weird
yeah so if you met a guy and he told you
he wasn't what if you met a dude and
he's what age would you be like you're
still a virgin I can't like if he's 23
would it bother you if versus 30 like
yeah probably 25 25 26 yeah I guess I
know cuz I'm thinking like I'm not
hooking up with 21 year olds on the Reg
but you get it I get 21
yes yeah do you have a cut-off age that
you won't that you're just like I can't
even I mean since we're 18 you know it's
a great example of this okay I'll call
him out so this is a wild now episode I
met Matt ryf when he was 17 okay and
that little boy had so much game and he
was macking on me so hard and I remember
being like dude you're selling at the
time I was like it's so cute and
adorable yeah that this little kid is
magic so yeah and had so much calm it's
so smooth yeah yeah yeah right well now
mash 21 and he's hot as [ __ ] I think
Matt is like a hot I wouldn't forgive me
I couldn't because I
see him as like a 20 I still see him as
like 17 year old yeah yeah but like now
I just think it's so funny cuz I'm like
alright well like if I had just met him
now and he did the same thing then would
I like I don't know if I could hook up
with like a 21 you're like you're young
what are you 24 back yeah over yeah so
like you could would you go you could
hook up the 20 it wouldn't get I
probably would yeah but this image
didn't know cuz you watch him grow a
little bit right I remember
I'm definitely hearing at one time and
he was just like his brain wasn't there
you know like little things you're just
like oh that's cute yeah they're so
eager to please but they also don't
really know what they're doing so it's
like there's a little bit of you mean
like in bed yeah yeah oh yeah I think
like two summers ago that's when I
really started getting better really I
was just come as long as I did it take a
girl explaining it or did you just learn
by by like hooking up or was there like
one girl that was like do this do that
this is what I like my hooking up yeah
you know I'm hella I'm prideful so I'm
not going I don't know he wants you to
tell me what's wrong I just want you to
know I just want to know that it's going
right yeah yeah I'm gonna do whatever I
can to make it go right was there a
moment when you were like I want to get
that Earth it's like I want to be really
good at this or like cuz some guys
really get off on getting the girl off
as many like some guys want to be like
the best you ever had other guys don't
care yeah I'm sort of in between I know
before I kind of I let some girls down
this will never happen trash disgruntled
like back to the lab guys remember there
was an app I forget what it was called
that was out for a little while where
you could rate people different things
it was like a rating system but sex was
like one of the things yeah and I just
remember being like this app is almost
not fair cuz if a guy rated a girl like
this he would look like the biggest
[ __ ] p.m. yeah but the girls would
rate these guys and like the reviews
were so honest it was like so scathing
and embarrassing I was going on the app
for my guy friends yeah I try to see who
can writing fake fake ones to make them
sound good because I felt sorry for them
because the things the girls were
writing were so mean yeah
Josh oh yeah
I wouldn't want that oh that would be
that would suck sooner by yourself
I would like cry I cry when I read like
comments on my youtube channel I would
definitely cry somebody put an app like
Kay is boring can't [ __ ] always has a
show it's already meet guys with like
they have a different like yeah I feel
like I've let some guys down too but
it's just like then you got to realize
like it's like every virgin like every
dicks different and like sometimes
there's guys who like getting whiskey to
earth they've been drinking or like
doing drugs like they can still do
whatever and then there's some guys that
are like yeah it's just not and you're
just like me like no and then if there's
times where you like man I remember when
I was in high school maybe my freshman
year college just one guy was like and
looking back I'm like I was so dumb but
he was like you know girls never got me
off by giving me a [ __ ] motivated I
was like
here we go [ __ ] line to that I do
that's a guys I tell guys that no guy
can get me off by going down on me all
the time have you ever had a guy going
down on you and then ask like if you're
not paying attention or if you're not
focused if like 20 minutes goes by like
what's wrong you're too in your head
like you can't and it's just like [ __ ]
no guys do that - do ya do if if to be
honest if I can tell if they start and I
can tell they got no skill at that
you're like you just bring them up after
like about yeah - five minutes of that
I'll be like I'm just dying to [ __ ] you
just give me a quick yeah well I faked I
faked it all like I faked it I know you
shouldn't I know you should never fake
it cuz guys never learn but if I'm with
the guy and no he's never gonna get me
off and I know this isn't gonna have a
future because he's never gonna get me
off I do fake it because I'm nice that's
and I want them to feel like they did
alright that's a real reason I do it and
to end it quicker for all the girls like
Kate around the world keeping these men
saying we had a good rapport like if we
were to keep it like that
I don't know well I did date a guy is
that terrible no I think
full disclosure I dated a guy that was
treating me very well but I wasn't super
attracted to him and I tried to be I
tried to be we [ __ ] maybe four times
and the first two times I was wasted I
am and then the third time I was just
like trying so hard to be into it and I
just wasn't and then finally I just told
him I actually had to tell him I was
like listen you're so sweet it treat me
so well and I feel
awful but I'm just not this I got this
sex it's just not good enough for that
in person yeah it's not good enough for
me I just I was married for 10 years I'd
shitty sex I want hot sex yeah and he
was like I'm kind of out of practice I
can get better and I was like I'm gonna
get gonna work out all girls need is
hard dick and a girlfriend not true how
do you feel like when I feel like
something with Danny is just like you
could get a guy that's gonna like every
now and then a girl has like she has a
bucket of [ __ ] that she just needs to
say at the end of the day sometimes like
she that's all she wants and all she
wants it's like somebody to like he
doesn't even have to like provide
feedback just be like respond maybe one
word and like some guys are just like I
don't care why you tell me this some
guys will respond in one way like what
do you how do you if you're dating the
girl like we look if she's telling it
like a five-minute story and you know
it's going nowhere
what do you do so you'll keep faking it
for I got a time limit on faking it okay
I'm out of faith we take it but I'm more
like you know I do comedy so I'm wearing
[ __ ]
all right don't ask questions why is
that in there I'll try to make you sound
stupid at the end of your all you do is
joke everything's funny I don't know why
you came in bad I ought to come in
laughing yeah comedians we see things a
little different but I mean it's it's
funny you say thanks I was just thinking
about it when we were talking like I
read an article about how basically like
the problem with relationships these
days is that women want the man to play
the role of the woman and the man like
we want him to be our best friend and
also be this like alpha male who can
like change the tire and yeah the [ __ ]
out of you and it's like why do you want
the guy to be both because I'm trying to
work on having a lot of good girlfriends
and I can dump my friends [ __ ] on my
girlfriends so that when I see the dude
it can just be like him explain your
yeah because eventually that calms but
like this article was saying basically
that girls they try to turn the guy into
like their beer left yeah quick and I
find those things elsewhere a lot of the
times like if he can't satisfy every
single need like you gotta just know
that you can't get everything out of one
person you have to find it in other
places but then I feel like Becky start
this is like you're getting ready to
like miss down the road but like marry
someone you get less and less don't your
friends right yeah you're gonna need it
out of them like you yeah you can't
expect it right away but like at what
point are you like I need a little more
yeah I think the more girl out of you
don't yeah no totally I think you start
to care actually care about the girl
does it come naturally to kind of be
like you want to know like oh how did
that thing go today or like how or do
guys really just not care I think
naturally I'm sort of a caring person
yeah I get you know I'm doing my thing
I'm just hoping that you are yeah it's
just the like that they ask though
that's like enough I don't want a guy
even if deep dive [ __ ] right yes I'm
like sweet when a guy's text me like
how'd your like not even how'd your set
go but like if it was something I was
like the other day I shot a pilot you
know I told this guy that I've been
seeing that I was going to shoot this
pilot and I was kind of like running
some ideas by him and stuff and then
afterwards he never you never asked how
it went and it kind of bugged me and
like the smallest thing or just like
how'd it go and me just mean like oh so
great would be huge but I think guys
because guys don't need it mm-hmm like
we do it for guys cuz it's our impulse
right like I'm sure if you're dating a
guy you're like how'd that go yeah yeah
but I don't think guys can't give a [ __ ]
if we ever asked or not they're just
like do you care
we know it's all about the end result
like what's the end result all the
in-between talk we like we're this is
whatever yeah did the bill get paid it's
just white noise you know is why not
that should be the name of like a new
group yeah title for today white noise
black man white noise is the description
y'all got a scream what like that got to
be y'all thing like just screaming at
the dam had so many questions and we're
running out of time this is you guys
were amazing one more question
oh I met my own personal question due
date white girls um okay I lost my
virginity to a white girl oh not really
consistently dated white girls yeah why
it was just there's not that I didn't
like them uses the girls that had like
me I like them back you know I don't
have white girls knocking down my door
you're a good kisser when we kissed
there was nice
Becky did you do date a black guys right
like I only knows I heard you on stage
say like I hooked up with the black yeah
- what one was like very light-skinned
oh yeah
loved it and then jay-z
I love black guys daddy - you know what
I think it is about why I like black
guys is that tell me if this sounds
super racist but black guys it seems to
me it can put up with more like sassy
independent like strong with like I can
scare off a lot of white guys it's hard
for me to scare a black guy off and I
feel like they're more blunt yes
a white girl I mean the white guys be
running scared cuz you got to do four
days here not talking about no [ __ ]
that's what she's saying like Reika
I just feel black guys are just more
like they wear everything on their
sleeve kind of like they're just like
more outspoken more I don't know there's
just some quality I really like about
black guys yeah even if it's like a good
or bad thing like they'll say whatever
and you're just like that's so nice just
like oh that's here yeah I feel like I
can I know you what's going like what do
you feel like there's less games and
trying to figure it out yeah yeah yeah
like even if even he's [ __ ] twenty
other girls like you're the only doing
I'm seeing other people wait like
they're just tell you yeah I like that I
like that like that and just like good
at like romance and a lady yeah you
think we're both of them better Abed did
the race right bad yeah I'm gonna be
honest like why you know it may be
difficult to big I had to get
oh no just okay yeah I was gonna say I
don't think that if the dick thing is
necessarily always true because I'm
always too big but it was like you gotta
get used to the you know that's right
forever that's what it's supposed to do
yeah unless you blew out and now I can't
adjust to nobody
you cannot blow out a vagina man it
feels different
oh yeah Kegel exercises well yeah but
not even always on purpose but like some
of the this class that's fitness class
I've been taking you can come take it if
you want with me anytime there's a lot
of there's a lot of clenching clenching
so I feel like it's getting like extra
work yeah if you work your glutes a lot
to you kind of yeah I just do a lot of
squeezin hell yeah practicing kegels
watching Maury while I'm eating [ __ ]
soup like when I went to watch yeah I
watched that trash TV oh yeah that's
true like Jerry Springer never go on TV
and fight for $30 well you guys were
awesome this was super fun like I said
we couldn't last our 62 minutes my long
cuz you guys are funny as [ __ ] you guys
want to plug it probably something
before we go
no boy all deaf Digital roast me all
digital new show two new shells on all
digital yeah it's just a lot I've been
working a lot since Jamie I don't think
I've stopped working that's a good size
yeah just a lot of stuff in the works
hit me on instagram Teddy rate comedy
what's the late setting on snapchat
while we're now every Thursday MTV one
not two MTV one if you wanna be a bad
game it's at 10:00 to 10:00 p.m. - okay
I am coming Thank You Robinson for an
Instagram you get back your Robin
Becky our Robinson on Twitter Becky Rob
on snap hit me up is this out now he's
coming out now next Friday
okay September 29th I think is a
Thursday that the wildin out episode
with Jay Leno's airing that was a real
fun one Bela's worries there's so much
fun and yeah show dates are up on my
website Becky - Robinson calm yeah you
guys are killing it I love you thank you
guys for watching Dave Pelz follow me @
KQ funny make sure you check out all the
podcasts on all things comedy see you
next time bye